hi everyone this is matt nava from giant
squid
i'm excited to share more with you today
about our upcoming game the pathless
the pathless is an open world mythic
adventure game set in a vast forest
you play as the hunter who along with
your eagle companion
seeks to lift a curse of darkness that
plagues the world
the hunter is a master of archery she
can shoot talismans to fill her dash
meter which allows her to bound across
the landscape
fluid dynamic movement is at the core of
the pathless
so the game's unique take on archery is
all about timing
not aiming down sights this design was
critical
to making it possible to shoot even
while moving fast and performing
acrobatic maneuvers
you instantly feel as skilled as the
hunter herself
with help from the eagle you can even
fly
bond between the hunter and the eagle is
central in the pathos
[Music]
you can gain altitude while you glide by
[Music]
flapping
make sure you pet the eagle to keep it
clean and in good flying condition
you'll find secrets all over the island
if you know where to look
collecting crystals will let you upgrade
the eagle's ability to flap
[Music]
you'll also discover larger puzzles to
solve in ancient structures
[Music]
the pathless is all about finding your
own way forward so unlike most open
world games there's no map instead
the hunter can use her mask to peer into
the spirit world
and discover distant landmarks it even
shows you where you've been
getting to higher vantage points will
let you see further with spirit vision
[Music]
giant cursed spirits the source of the
darkness will pose a constant threat to
you on your quest
they will try to separate you from the
eagle
stay still in the light to avoid
detection
me
you won't be able to take on the cursed
spirits until you've returned light to
the obelisks
when the obelisks are restored the
cursed spirits will be vulnerable
chase them down through the forest to
corner them in a dramatic final battle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the hunter and eagle will have to defeat
the cursed spirits to bring light back
to the world
i hope you've enjoyed this overview of
the pathless
we've only scratched the surface there's
so much more to explore
and discover hypothesis is coming out
later this year
thanks for watching
[Music]